[Applause]
I'm Lila Kinney I'm the executive
director of Casa I had the great
privilege to be able to put together
this session on the wearable and I just
want to remind you of the way in which
we framed it we when you think about the
history of interest in wearable act
wearables at MIT going back to the 90s
in the Media Lab everything from
portable cameras that feed man and his
colleagues used to wear around that were
premonitions of Google glass and so
forth we have a really strong history in
this area which you will hear about I
think from a couple of our both our
moderator and one of our speakers but I
wanted to do something a little
different and that is to sort of
crosscut this with two very powerful
artistic statements on other really
extreme ends of the spectrum on the one
hand the literal wearable from a fashion
designer who for more than 20 years has
been doing experimentations with
textiles that transform themselves and
creating all kinds of a conceptual
approached his fashion that has really
moved the field to another kind of
artist who works on the body in extreme
conditions in outer space in
otherworldly context so I regard my job
is to prepare it is to be as brief as
possible so we can move into these two
conversations that are framing the
session and in the midst we have a media
scholar
and social scientist who will help us to
unpack some of the ethical and social
dimensions of these this whole questions
around wearable I'll briefly remind you
it's printed in your program of the
premise of the session and that is that
the integration of the human body and
clothing with technology has propelled
art computationally enhanced fashion
design and material science far beyond I
think what we used to think about and
talk about notions and visions of the
cyborg in the 1960s so in this session I
want to explore the multiplicity
of these developments from the emergence
of conceptual fashion design and
wearable computing in the 1990s to
current experiments with electronic and
reactive text both we have a new
Institute here at MIT advanced
functional fibers of America huge
consortium public-private thing we've
done shrink-wrapped spacesuits all kinds
of material science explorations in this
area and of course the proliferation a
portable sensing systems that provide
data feedback to monitor health or
improve athletic performance in many
ways so what we want to do ultimately is
to bring this question of the
intersection of the digital and material
back to the body and the position of the
body in space and to ask what it means
today to be human
not so human where is this intersection
and proliferation so I now like to
introduce the panelists and the order in
which they will speak our first
conversation will would we be between
Hussein Shanahan Salah yang excuse me a
fashion designer who as I mentioned for
more than 20 years has used clothing as
a platform to display materials that
change state and transform themselves
his work is characterized by an
adventurous approach to the runway show
and he's been able to use these
performances really as a mechanism a
means to address all kinds of issues
from disembodiment metamorphosis forced
migration all kinds of interesting
social and self representational issues
he will be in conversation with Michelle
Fenimore who is the I know you have the
title yes appending the penny Vinick
curator of textual arts at the Museum of
Fine Arts here in Boston I hope that
many of you were able to see the show
that she curated recently called textile
in which Hussein and others some people
from Media Lab showed their work she is
also the author of
Hollywood before glamour fashion and
American silent film natasha shul is an
associate professor of media culture and
communication at New York University but
for many years was oh sorry my slide
excuse me where's my here we go
sorry here you go there are two saying
for many these we'll just rotate through
so Natasha looks for many years here at
the science technology and society
program at MIT her next book keeping
track sensor technology self-regulation
and the data-driven life concerns the
rise of digital self tracking
technologies and old questions that they
raise about self governance and identity
and self surveillance this is a textile
show and here's Natasha and you can see
this interesting representation of her
with a sort of mood band and some of the
gadgets that she has analyzed and
surveyed then we will in our final
conversation hear from Kristina akka
Pettis who is the creative director of
Ginkgo Bioworks she's a biologist and
arter artist a writer and a creative
director at ginkgo via works is which is
an organism design company which I hope
will hear a little bit more about she
has done a lot of work with artists in
particular for example she made cheese
cultured from the artist oleifera live
whose tears she will be in conversation
with Lucy McCrae who is a sci-fi artist
and film director and self-proclaimed
body architect she as I mentioned
imagines the body in extreme condition
and creates all kinds of futuristic
scenarios and installations
she understands the body in a sort of
complex scenarios that really question
the boundaries between the natural and
the artificial and Christina and Lucy in
particular I think want to bring the
conversation into some feminist
territory really questioning questioning
what the wearable is what its impact
will be on future scenarios of
reproduction biology and so forth so
with that I give you our first
conversation between Hussein silicon and
Michelle anymore thank you
[Applause]